- [Narrator] This is the
Attwater's prairie chicken.
(gentle piano music)
A century ago, there were a
million of them roaming around.
Today, less than 100 are left in the wild,
and are considered one of
the most endangered birds
in North America.
They are native to the coastal
areas of Texas and Louisiana.
Attwater's prairie chickens are small,
averaging about a
foot-and-a-half in a size,
and weighing two pounds.
They prefer short and tall
grass in their habitats,
and have a diverse diet,
including grass shoots,
flowers, seeds and insects.
Urbanization and other
forms of habitat loss
have been one of the major factors
in the steep decline of their population.
The Houston Zoo runs one of
the captive breeding programs
to help reintroduce these
critically endangered birds
to the wild.
This is the Attwater's prairie chicken.